I deliberately didn't talk about this
yesterday because I wanted to just allow
a little more time for information to
come out and we now have a lot more
details about this completely out of
control mag a clown who pushed his way
into the camera area at Donald from Sal
Paso Texas build the wall rally on
Monday night which we covered yesterday
and attacked a cameraman from the BBC
had to be restrained obviously the guy
was wearing the requisite red maggot
shoving reporters knocking over cameras
and tripods yelling F the media and this
all happened during the speech right
after the point where Donald Trump
attacked the media again something that
he's been doing for years at this point
so I've got a few different clips and
audio that I'm going to show you here to
begin with is video of the camera that
was actually hit going from just showing
Donald Trump to a jumble of video as
this maggot at wearing clown slams into
it it was happening during a key moment
of Trump speech during which he was
listing races and ethnicities which is a
fun part of any Magali
[Applause]
in the history of our contract
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh man what an atmosphere at these
rallies here's video of the guy being
escorted out to cheers of Trump Trump
Trump
[Applause]
so absolute and total chaos reporters
yelling for police no police were nearby
here's more video from Jorge Salgado who
was there as well
[Music]
these rallies are more reminiscent of
wrestling events than they are of places
where political issues are discussed and
then lastly here's another video with
the guys last moment of glory tipping
his hat to the crowd and yelling make
America great again as he is escorted
out
[Applause]
yeah so this is about many things this
is about hostility towards media
fomented by Donald Trump in a way we've
not seen any recent American president
do this is about violence physical
violence by the right this is about a
general atmosphere of aggression at
Trump events I sort of not really even
jokingly of ten percent jokingly said
the atmosphere here is like a WWE event
it's basically true right I mean there's
this a constant undertone of aggression
that that takes place at these events
and it's yet another one of these lie
riddle to trump rallies where everything
that comes out of trumps mouth is
accepted completely uncritically but I
think the really important focus after
this incident Pat should be that the
reporters have to have these incidents
prosecuted to the fullest extent
possible BBC and the reporter should
file suit there's endless video evidence
here and you know on the one hand you've
got Trump fomenting aggression towards
media on the other hand you have people
who are feeling license to go further
than the law allows in actions against
members of the media and the the one we
can't control Trump's rhetoric but what
we can control is that every time
something like this happens we have to
use the law to the fullest extent
possible to make sure that there are
consequences for being aggressive
towards members of the media I totally
agree with that and also I view this as
like a perfect metaphor because it's not
like the guy attacked an opinion
reporter he attacked a cameraman and the
job of a cameraman is to present things
as they happen right just to film the
events that take place in front of you
and for whatever reason he was just
finding that to be too obscene that that
can't get out to the public it goes into
this alternative fact thing I think that
they've been supporting for a while now
yeah and I think the bigger picture is
sort of what you're getting to which is
that we we have now a complete and total
disconnect from the realities of what
quote media is even doing as some kind
of amorphous umbrella term and what the
values are that we claim to support and
as you point out a camera person is
there to keep the camera trained on
what's taking place and to pass it
through to people so that they can can
sumit absolutely horrible incident and
we'll see if they're ultimately are any
consequences for the perpetrator here
one of the days sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman which is a free service
that I myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link